[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: OK, so let's
continue our study of sequences
of real numbers.
So we've seen special types of
sequences, monotone sequences,
before.
And then in the
previous lecture,
we looked at sequences
obtained from sequences,
namely the sequences that give
you the lim sup and lim inf.
And we showed that
these are actually
limits of subsequences.
Now I'm going to
define what looks
like a new class of sequences.
But we'll see it's actually not.
These are called
Cauchy sequences.
So "coe-shee"-- not
"couch-ee," not "cawt-shee"--
Cauchy, so a French guy.
So it's pronounced Cauchy and
probably not even pronounced
like that.
It's probably got a
different pronunciation
by people who
actually speak French.
So what is the definition
of a Cauchy sequence?
A Cauchy sequence,
intuitively, it's
a sequence so that if you go
far enough out in the sequence,
any two entries in that
sequence are close together.
So convergent sequences
had the property
that if you go far enough out,
the entries in the sequence
are getting close
to a real number.
Cauchy sequence is
that any two entries
are close to each other.
So a Cauchy sequence, so
we say a sequence is Cauchy
if we're all epsilon
positive, there
exists an M,
natural number, such
that if n is bigger
than or equal to M and k
is bigger than or equal
to M, then xn minus xk
is less than epsilon.
So maybe not write if.
I mean, it's the same
statement, but since it looks--
so it'll look a little more
like previous statements
when we put a "for all" there.
So you have a definition here.
It's the definition
of a new thing.
You should now try
to look at an example
and then possibly negate the
definition to see if you really
understand it.
So an example of
a Cauchy sequence
is x of n equals 1 over
n, our favorite sequence.
So let's prove this.
So all we have is
the definition.
So we have to verify that
x of n equals 1 over n
verifies the definition
of being Cauchy.
So just like when we try to
prove something is convergent,
which is a "for all" epsilon
statement, the first thing
you have to do is let
epsilon be positive.
And then I have to choose M
and show that that capital
M produces this statement here.
So choose M, a natural
number, so that 1 over M
is less than epsilon over 2.
So I could phrase that as
capital M being bigger than 2
over epsilon, but I'm going
to phrase it this way.
Now we have to show
that it works-- namely,
if I take n bigger than
or equal to capital M
and k bigger than or
equal to a capital M,
then this difference
is less than epsilon.
Then if n is bigger
than or equal to M,
k is bigger than or equal to M,
and I look at 1 over n minus 1
over k, this is less than
or equal to, by the triangle
inequality, the
absolute value of each
of these added together, which
is just 1 over n plus 1 over k.
And since these are both
bigger than or equal to M,
each 1 is less than
or equal to 1 over M 1
over M, so I get 2 over M,
which, by our choice of M,
is less than epsilon.
So x of n equals 1 over n is an
example of a Cauchy sequence.
So let's negate the
definition, and then we'll
look at an example of a
sequence which is not Cauchy.
And as you'll probably guess, if
this is our favorite sequence,
which converges, our favorite
sequence which doesn't converge
will be an example of a
sequence which is not Cauchy.
And this should shouldn't
come as a surprise.
Because, again, a sequence
which is Cauchy, if you
go far enough out,
any two entries
are close to each other.
But if we look at, for
example, the sequence minus 1
to the n, which is just
minus 1 plus 1 minus 1,
any two entries will differ by--
or you can always
choose two entries--
that differ by 2 in distance.
So let's negate this
definition to get what it means
for something not to be Cauchy.
So we'll not write all that out.
So x of n is not Cauchy if--
so every time we
see a "for all,"
it becomes "there exists."
If there exists a bad
epsilon 0 positive
such that for all
M, a natural number,
you can find two entries
further out than M
that are greater than epsilon
0 distance to each other.
So there exists n bigger
than or equal to M
and k bigger than or equal to
M such that x of n minus x of k
is bigger than or equal
to this bad epsilon.
OK
Again, the definition
of Cauchy means
that, as long as I go far
enough out in the sequence,
this distance is supposed
to be less than epsilon.
So for all epsilon positive,
there exists a capital M
so that I have this picture.
If I choose x sub k plus
1, then it should also
be within distance epsilon
to x sub n or x sub k.
So they're getting closer
and closer together.
The negation means that they're
not getting closer and closer
together to each other.
So there exists
some small distance
so that you can always go as
far out as you want and find
two entries that are greater
than epsilon 0 distance
to each other.
So what's an example of that?
Like I said, the sequence
minus 1 to the n is not Cauchy.
That just doesn't look right.
There we go.
Now it is.
So this is not Cauchy.
So that means there should
exist some bad epsilon 0.
So I can go as far
out as I want and find
two entries in the sequence
differing from each other
by epsilon 0 in distance.
So basically, I can
always find two entries
in the sequence which
differ from each other by 2.
So that'll be my bad epsilon 0.
So if you like, here's a proof.
Choose epsilon 0 equals 2.
Let M be a natural number.
So now we have to find
an element of entries
in the sequence further out than
M whose distance to each other
is bigger than or equal to 2.
We can just take M plus
1 and capital M. Choose n
equals M and k equals M plus 1.
So these are both bigger
than or equal to M.
Then minus 1 to the
n minus 1 to the k,
this is equal to 1 minus minus
1 after I factor out a minus 1
to the capital M,
which equals 2.
So minus 1 to the
n is not Cauchy.
So I, at the beginning,
said that this
will look like a definition
of a new type of sequence,
but it's not, really.
So as it turns out, the
elements of the sequence
are getting closer
and closer together
as you go far enough out.
So
They're all kind of clustering
near each other, which kind of
makes you think they're all
clustering near something
in the real number line.
And therefore, maybe, the
sequence is convergent.
Now, this is true--
and we'll prove this--
that a sequence is Cauchy if
and only if it's convergent.
Now, this is true only
for the real numbers.
And I'll say a little bit
about this in a minute--
or not only true for
the real numbers,
but it's not true for
the rational numbers.
And I'll get to that
in just a second.
So what we're going to prove
is that a sequence is Cauchy if
and only if it is convergent.
So the first thing
I want to show
is that Cauchy
sequences are bounded.
So the proof of this
statement is essentially
the same as the proof
that convergent sequences
are bounded.
So let me draw a picture that
goes along with this proof.
So as long as I
go far enough out,
there exists an M so
that for all n bigger
than or equal to capital
M, I can say this.
Let's look at this entry x
of M. Then for all n bigger
than or equal to capital
M, all of the other entries
have to be within a certain
distance to x sub n,
based on the
definition of Cauchy.
So let's say I make
that distance 1.
And let's say 0's over
here, just for this picture.
So then for all n
for all n bigger
than or equal to capital M,
x sub n lies in this interval
here.
And therefore, we'll get
that x of n is bounded.
So the way this picture looks,
I'm going to write it this way.
It's 1 plus 1.
Now, that handles all n bigger
than or equal to capital M.
So we just need to deal
with the first capital
M minus 1 other guy.
So maybe there's capital
M minus 1 is over here.
Capital X sub 1 is over there.
Capital X sub 2 is over here.
So then our bound
will just be this one,
which handles all of the n
bigger than or equal to M
plus the absolute values of
these guys that we missed.
So since xn is
Cauchy, there exists
and M, a natural number,
such that for all n
bigger than or equal
to M, and k bigger
than or equal to M, x sub n
minus x sub k is less than 1
in distance.
So this is certainly
true for k equals
capital M. So this
implies for all n bigger
than or equal to M, x
sub n minus x sub capital
M is less than 1.
So now, if I use the
triangle inequality,
I can show that the
previous implies
that for all n bigger
than or equal to M,
if I look at the absolute
value of x sub n,
this is equal to x sub n minus
x sub capital M plus capital M.
And this is less than or
equal to the absolute value
of this guy plus the
absolute value of this guy.
And this is bounded by 1.
So in summary, I've shown
that for all n bigger
than or equal to this
fixed integer, capital M, x
sub n is less than or
equal to x sub capital
M in absolute value plus 1.
So that's for all
little n bigger than
or equal to capital
M. So now I just
need to pick a big enough number
that bounds the first capital M
entries that are not
covered by this inequality.
Capital M is fixed.
So let B be the absolute
value of x sub 1
plus absolute value of x sub
2 plus this fixed number now.
Then for all n bigger than
or equal to capital M,
I have, by this
inequality up here--
this is a sum of
non-negative numbers,
so this number is
certainly bigger than
or equal to just this part.
And if I have n bigger than
equal to 1 and less than M,
then x of n, the absolute
value of this guy
is going to be one of these
that appears here, which
is certainly less than
or equal to if I add
on this number and the
others, which is less than
or equal to B. So now I've found
a B which is non-negative which
bounds all the absolute values.
And therefore, this proves
that the sequence is bounded.
So we've shown that a
Cauchy sequence is bounded.
And so what I'm now going
to show is the following.
So again, all of the entries
are getting close to each other.
They're kind of clustering
near each other.
So it kind of feels like
they want to converge.
And this next theorem
says that, well,
if you've identified a
limit along a subsequence,
then, in fact, the entire
sequence converges.
So of course, this is not true
for an arbitrary sequence.
If a subsequence converges--
or I should say, for
an arbitrary sequence,
it's not true that a
subsequence converging implies
a full sequence converging.
We have minus 1 to the n for
which a subsequence converges,
but the whole sequence
does not converge.
But if we make the
additional hypothesis
that the sequence is
Cauchy, then the sequence
converges if and only if
that subsequence converges.
So the statement of the
theorem is following.
If x sub n is Cauchy and there
exists a subsequence which
is converging to some number--
call it x-- then the whole
sequence converges to x.
So what I was saying right
before I stated this theorem is
that if I hide this
part and just say,
there exists a subsequence
which is converging to x,
this does not imply that the
full sequence converges to x.
Because we had this example
of minus 1 to the n.
But if I also assume
the sequence is Cauchy,
then it does follow that
Cauchy plus subsequence
converging implies the
full sequence converges.
So I want to show that
xn converges to x.
So want to show--
and we're going to do this
just by using the definition,
by verifying this
through the definition,
not using the squeeze theorem
or anything like that.
So let epsilon be positive.
Since xn is Cauchy, there
exist M0, a natural number
such that for all n
bigger than or equal to M0
and k bigger than
or equal to M0, x
sub n minus x sub k is
less than epsilon over 2.
Why this epsilon over 2?
Or why should you
not be surprised?
Well, we have two
assumptions here.
So like we did when we did
convergence of products
of sequences and so on,
which had two assumptions,
namely two sequences converged
to something, typically,
that means we'll have
two integers coming.
We'll choose a bigger integer
and then some inequalities
to get an epsilon.
So that's a little bit
of a rambling answer
to why we get an epsilon over 2
here, or why we put one there.
Since the subsequence-- so this
subsequence converges to x--
there exists another
integer, M sub 1 such
that if k is bigger than
or equal to M sub 1,
then x sub n sub k minus x
is less than epsilon over 2.
So maybe I should have used
a different letter here.
Let's use a little m.
Because I don't
want you to think
these have to be the same k.
So now we'll choose an integer
bigger than both M1 and M2
and show that it works.
Choose M to be M0 plus M1.
Now we need to show this works.
And if n is bigger than
or equal to M, so let me,
actually, make a
first observation
before I go to the n bigger
than or equal to capital M.
Then, since n sub k is bigger
than or equal to k for all
of k, a natural number-- just
because the n sub k is there
in increasing
sequence of integers,
which starts at least at 1--
and since n sub k is bigger
than or equal to k for all k,
this implies that the integer
n sub capital M is bigger
than or equal to
M, which, remember,
is M0 plus M1, which
implies that n sub M is
bigger than or equal
to M0 and n sub M is
bigger than or equal to M1.
So I just wanted to make
this preliminary observation.
And now we'll go to showing
that this capital M works.
So now, if n is bigger
than or equal to capital
M, and I look at x sub n
minus x, an absolute value,
and add and subtract x sub n
capital M capital M minus x
and use the triangle
inequality, then--
so since n is bigger than
or equal to capital M, which
is bigger than or
equal to M0, that
means n is bigger
than or equal to M0.
And then n sub M we just showed
is bigger than or equal to 0.
So by this inequality, I
get that the first term
is less than epsilon over 2.
And now, so M is
certainly bigger than
or equal to M sub 1.
And therefore, I will get that
this part is less than epsilon
over 2 because of
this inequality.
So that choice of
capital M works.
And now, we'll
prove the following,
that a sequence is convergent
if and only if it's Cauchy.
So this is a two-way street.
So we need to show the
left implies the right
and then the right
implies the left.
So this direction
is, in fact, easy.
Based on what we've done--
I shouldn't say it's easy--
but what we've done so
far, it quickly follows.
So we're assuming
x sub n is Cauchy.
I'm trying to show
it's convergent.
So if x sub n is
Cauchy, this implies
that x sub n is bounded,
the sequence is bounded,
which implies by the
Bolzano-Weierstrass theorem
that x sub n has a
convergent subsequence.
And by the theorem
we just proved,
if a Cauchy sequence has
a convergent subsequence,
it must be convergent.
Now, for the converse
direction, that xn
is convergent implies xn
is Cauchy, well, so this
should not come as a surprise.
Let me draw a picture.
Let's suppose x sub
n is converging to x,
and epsilon is positive.
Then, since the
xn's are converging
to x, if I draw a
little interval around x
of total length epsilon--
so x minus epsilon over 2
and x plus epsilon over 2--
then I will find, as long
as so then there exists M
so that, for all n bigger
than or equal to capital M,
all of the x sub n's
lie in this interval.
They all lie in this
interval because they
have to be within
distance epsilon over 2
to x if the xn's
are converging to x.
And since they lie
in this interval,
the distance between
any two of them
can only be as big as the
length of the interval, which
is epsilon.
So this is essentially
the picture
of why a convergence
sequence has to be Cauchy.
So now let's turn this
picture into math.
We have to verify xn is
Cauchy through the definition.
That's all we have.
So let epsilon be positive.
Since the xn's
converge to x, there
exists an integer M sub
0, a natural number,
such that for all n bigger
than or equal to M sub 0, x
sub n minus x is less
than epsilon over 2.
And so we'll choose the M
for our definition of Cauchy
to be this M sub 0.
And if n is bigger
than or equal to M
and k is bigger
and I look at the absolute
value of x sub n minus x sub k
and add and subtract x and
use the triangle inequality,
this is less than
or equal to x sub
n minus x, an absolute
value, plus x minus x sub k.
Each of these is less
than epsilon over 2
since n is bigger than
or equal to capital M,
and k is bigger than
or equal to capital M.
So this is less than epsilon
over 2 plus epsilon over 2
equals epsilon.
And therefore, xn is Cauchy.
Now I want to make
a brief remark
about the previous theorem.
So remember how this
whole story started off?
There was something wrong with
the rational numbers, namely,
they didn't contain
the square root of 2.
So we couldn't solve
the algebraic equation
x squared minus 2 equals 0.
But this also, then,
turned into the rationals
not being complete in
the sense of order.
Not every non-empty
bounded set had a supremum.
It didn't have the least
upper bound property.
But you can also interpret this
lack of having square root of 2
as somehow saying
that the rationals are
incomplete in this sense.
So hopefully, at the
end of this class,
we'll be able to get
to metrics basis.
But so what do I mean by that?
Let's say I look
at this statement
now within the universe
of rational numbers.
So now, if this sequence
is rational numbers--
meaning sequences are only
sequences of rational numbers,
limits are only elements
of the rational numbers,
epsilon is only a rational
number, and so on-- then
we still have many
of the same theorems
that we proved--
not all of them,
and I'll indicate
which ones don't hold.
But if we only
work in rationals,
then we always do have a
convergence implies Cauchy,
meaning convergent
sequences are Cauchy.
But Cauchy sequences are
not necessarily convergent.
Again, what's the
example here, or what's
the intuitive example?
Take x sub n so
that x of n is in Q.
And now viewed in the
universe of real numbers,
x sub n's converge to root 2.
Then such a sequence would
be a Cauchy sequence.
We just proved that, basically.
So such a sequence would
be a Cauchy sequence
of rational numbers.
However, it would not converge
in the set of rational numbers.
It would converge to
the square root of 2,
which is not a rational number.
So because the square root of
2 is not a rational number,
this shows that the
rational numbers do not
have this completeness property
that Cauchy sequences converge.
So there's a whole,
still, to this day, kind
of industry of studying
spaces for which Cauchy
is equivalent to convergent.
These are called
complete metric spaces.
And then if you add a
little more structure,
they're called Banach
spaces and so on,
which are very important,
not just in math
but also for
formulating rigorously
a lot of the
underlying assumptions
for mathematical physics.
So if we're just looking
inside the rationals,
it does not follow that Cauchy
sequences always converge.
And now let's just
stop for a minute
and take stock of why this
was true for the real numbers.
What did we use going back?
So if you really go
back to the proof
of the Bolzano-Weierstrass--
so that's what we used here
to show that Cauchy
sequences converge--
we use the fact that the lim sup
and the lim inf always exists.
And lim sup and lim
inf, first off, they're
defined to be sups and
infs, which may not always
exist as rational numbers,
as we've already shown.
So that's definitely a
problem already there.
But even more so, when we prove
that every bounded monotone
sequence converges,
what we showed
was that this limit is
actually a sup of a certain set
or an inf of a certain set,
which, again, may or may not
exist if we're just looking
in the rational numbers.
Because the rational numbers do
not have the least upper bound
property.
So it really is the least
upper bound property
that gives us
convergence equivalent
to Cauchy for the real numbers.
So for R, the least
upper bound property is--
it has to be because
that's the main thing that
separates the two fields,
but I'm just reiterating this
here--
is the reason why convergent
is equivalent to Cauchy.
Now that I've proved that Cauchy
is equivalent to convergence,
maybe you'll ask, then why
did we introduce it at all?
If these two notions
are the same,
why even introduce
them if they're just
convergent sequences already?
And the reason is because to
show that a sequence converges,
you have to somehow
have your hands
on a candidate for the limit.
If you want to prove
that xn converges,
you have to somehow come up
with an x that it converges to.
And it's not always
clear how to find that x.
But Cauchy, although it's
equivalent to a convergent
in the set of real
numbers, doesn't
require you to find a
candidate for convergence.
All it requires
you to do is show
that, as long as you
go far enough out,
any two entries in the
sequence are close together
without requiring you
to come up with a limit.
See, computing limits
is quite difficult.
We're about to do series.
And there's maybe, I don't
know, five series people
can compute explicitly.
But you do know that there's
a ton of other series
that are actually convergent,
even though you don't know what
the limit as.
And why do you know that?
This is exactly
because and exactly
why people thought
of Cauchy sequences
to begin with in
much of analysis.
So again, just to
summarize this,
convergent sequences are nice.
But in practice, it's
difficult to get your hands
on what could be a
limit of a sequence,
especially if that sequence
is pretty complicated.
So if you're trying to show
a certain sequence converges,
it suffices, by what we've done
here, to show that it's Cauchy.
And that's a little bit
easier to do because that just
requires you to work with
the original sequence.
You don't have to
come up with a limit.
You can just take your sequence
and start playing directly
with the entries rather than
try to come up with a limit
explicitly.
So that's what we're
going to move on to
is series now, which,
as I said a minute ago,
is original reason why
people started developing
the foundations of
analysis, what we're talking
about right now, to begin with.
Because they were just kind
of doing very formal things
that ended up not
making sense, like they
were adding infinitely
many positive numbers
and coming up with
a negative number.
Well, that can't be right.
So all of this was
created, discovered--
however you want to phrase it--
to put on rigorous
foundations this next topic,
which is series.
And you dealt with
series in calculus,
so you know what a series is.
Maybe you don't
remember all the proofs
of the properties of series.
But suffice it to say, series
is a pretty good motivation
since it's one of the most
useful things that comes out
of math.
Series expansions are
how you solve ODEs, PDEs,
Taylor expansions.
All these things are, in
some sense, a form of series.
So being able to justify
them as being real things
is a necessity.
So the definition of
a series, for now,
really is just this symbol
I'm about to write down.
So given a sequence
x sub n, the symbol--
or maybe I'll just sometimes
write just the sum x sub n--
is what's called the series
associated to the sequence
x sub n.
So right now, that's
just a symbol.
We're going to interpret
this as a real number
in the following situation.
We say that the
series converges,
if the following sequence
given by s sub m equals--
so s sub m, this is the
element of the sequence.
And what is it?
It is the actual sum.
So this is not a formal thing.
This is just a finite
sum from n equals 1 to m.
So this is-- so this sequence
now, m equals 1 to infinity.
And these guys we call
partial sums converges.
So right now, if we just
have a sequence x sub n,
the series associated to that
sequence is just a symbol.
We say that this
series converges
if this sequence of
partial sums converge
and if s is this limit.
And we write s is
equal to the series
and treat the series
now as a number.
So in general, if
I have a sequence,
I just have this formal
symbol, which I'm writing down,
which I call a series
associated to it.
In the case that the sequence
of partial sums converges,
then I actually identify this
series with a real number
and treat it as a real number.
And so the way
I've written this,
the series is starting at 1.
But it doesn't
necessarily have to.
So just by shifting the index--
so let me just say here
that we don't necessarily
have to start a
series at n equals 1.
So this could be
sum from n equals 0
to infinity, in which case, we
have a sequence starting now
at x sub 0.
Or this could be starting
at 2, in which place
the sequence of x sub
n starts at n equals 2.
And then the sequence
of partial sums
would start at not m
equals 1 but m equals 0
or m equals 2, depending
on where the series starts.
So some examples.
The series sum from n equals
1 to infinity 1 over n
plus 1 times n, this
is a convergent series.
So why is this?
So let's look at the proof.
So we look at the
m-th partial sum--
this is the sum from n equals
1 to m of 1 over n plus 1n.
And this is equal to--
now, if I write 1 over n plus
1 times n as 1 over n minus 1
over n plus 1, this is
now the sum of 1 over n
plus-- these are finite sums,
so I can always split them up.
This should be a minus.
And so now, this is
equal to 1 plus 1/2
plus 1 over m minus 1/2
plus 1/3 plus 1 over m
plus 1 over n plus 1.
And you see all of these cancel.
And all that's left is
1 minus 1 over m plus 1.
So the m-th partial sum is equal
to 1 minus 1 over m plus 1.
And therefore, the
sequence of partial sums
is the limit as m
goes to infinity
of this, which is just 1.
And therefore, this
series converges.
Now, our favorite sequence,
which does not converge,
will give us a series
which does not converge.
So let's look at sum from n
equals 1 to infinity minus 1
to the n.
This does not converge.
So what's the proof?
The m-th partial sum,
this is equal to minus 1
plus 1 plus minus 1 up until
I get minus 1 to the m.
And therefore, this is always
equal to one of two things.
If m is odd, then I have an
odd number of these guys.
And therefore, the
minuses and pluses
cancel, just leaving
a minus 1 in the end--
this last one, the odd one.
And m is odd and 0 if m is even.
If I add up an even
number of these terms,
then all of the minus
1's and 1's cancel out,
so I just get 0.
And therefore, this sequence,
which is just minus 1
for m odd, 0 for m
even, does not converge.
And therefore, the
series does not converge.
So when I write this,
this is just a symbol.
This is just chalk
on a chalkboard.
It doesn't mean anything.
So let's go to another
series, which does converge.
And this is kind of
the one to which we
compare all other series,
essentially, as you'll see.
You have all these series tests
that you remember, hopefully,
from calculus that tell you
when a series converges.
But maybe, if you
remember the proof
or don't, how you do
that is you converge it
to one series, which
you do know how to sum.
So it was just by pure luck we
were able to compute the sum,
or compute the explicit
series for this guy.
Another one which we can do
that for is geometric series.
So the theorem is if
I have a real number
with absolute value less
than 1, then the series
starting now at 0 R
to the n converges.
And I can actually compute
the sum of this series.
And this is 1 over 1 minus r.
So what's the proof?
Let's look at the partial sums.
And we can actually
compute these, as well,
just as we were able to
do for the first example.
We compute that the sum from n
equals 0 to m of r to the m--
now, you can prove
this by induction.
I cannot exactly
remember if I did this--
I believe I did-- in
the second lecture
on induction, first or second
lecture on the induction.
But if I add up some
number raised to the n-th--
so this should be to the n--
power from 0 to m, this
is equal to 1 minus r
to the m plus 1 over 1 minus r.
And I guess two lectures
ago, we proved that
if the absolute value--
so let me state this now.
Two lectures ago, we proved
that if the absolute value of r
is less than 1, then limit as,
let's make it m, of r to the m
equals 0, which implies that--
so this was the
m-th partial sum--
which implies that the limit as
m goes to infinity of s sub m
equals the limit as m goes to
infinity of this thing, which
is, if you like--
so that plus 1 there just
multiplies r to the m by r.
And using the algebraic
facts we proved
about limits is 1
minus r time 0 over 1
minus r, which equals
1 over 1 minus r.
So now you ask about the other.
What about r bigger than 1?
Well, when r equals
minus 1, then we
get the second
example we looked at.
If we get r equals 1, then
that's just summing up 1,
and I'll leave it to you
to check that that does not
converge, that the sequence of
partial sums, if I just sum up
1 from n equals 0 to
m, is equal 2n plus 1,
which does not converge.
And let me make just a
kind of silly comment.
And maybe I didn't
explicitly make
this comment about sequences.
Maybe I forgot to
do that, as well.
So for a sequence, you could
start your sequence not
necessarily at the first entry.
Maybe you look at a, if you
like, new sequence where--
well, so we know from
sequences that subsequences
of convergent
sequences converge.
So if I, instead of looking at
the whole sequence, start at,
let's say, x100 and
then go x101, x102,
and that's the
sequence I look at,
well, that's a subsequence
of the original one, which,
if it converges, implies
that subsequence converges.
So all that is to say--
and for this simple way of
obtaining this new sequence--
all of that is to say
that to understand
if a sequence
converges, I don't have
to consider what happens for
the first finitely many terms
in the sequence,
meaning a sequence x
sub n converges if and only if
a sequence starting now at say,
n equals 100-- and 101, 102,
103 and so on-- converges.
And the same is true for series,
that a series converges if
and only if a series
converges, now,
starting at a different
point along the sequence.
So this is the
following theorem.
Let xn be a sequence, and let
capital M be a natural number.
Then n equals 1 to
infinity of x sub n.
This converges if and only
if the sequence, now starting
at capital M,
converges, meaning when
I have to decide whether
a series converges or not,
it doesn't matter
what's going on
for the first
finitely many terms.
What matters is
what's going on as I
keep adding terms from
further and further out
of this sequence.
And what's the proof?
The proof is just
expressing the partial sums
for this guy in terms of the
partial sums for this guy.
So a partial sum satisfied
for all m, sum from n
equals 1 to m, and now
x sub n as sum from n
equals capital M to m
x sub n plus sum from n
equals 1 to capital
M minus 1 x sub n.
So this is now just
a fixed number.
So this is a sequence of
partial sums corresponding
to this series.
This is a sequence of
partial sums corresponding
to this series.
And this is just a fixed number.
Therefore, if this
converges, then this side
converges to this plus this--
so maybe I'm going
a little quick.
But so if this
converges, then this
converges to this
minus this number.
And if this converges, then
this sequence of partial sums
converges to this limit
plus this fixed number.
And that's all I'm
going to write.
Now, coming back to the
usefulness of Cauchy sequences,
this is kind of
where they really
become useful is in
the study of series.
Because again, it's
difficult to sum.
So when I keep talking
saying the word sum a series,
I'm talking about find
the limit of partial sums.
But because we have this
equivalence between Cauchy
sequences and
convergent sequences,
to decide if a series
is convergent or not,
we can just decide if, in some
sense, it's Cauchy or not.
So let me make this definition.
We say that a series x sub
n is Cauchy if the sequence
of partial sums--
again, I'm just going to
put an m up top because this
may start at 0 or n equals 1
or something-- so the sequence
of partial sums is Cauchy.
And so let me just restate
what we proved for sequences
in terms of series.
So we proved that every
Cauchy sequence is convergent.
So a series is Cauchy means that
the sequence of partial sums
is Cauchy.
But we've proven that Cauchy
sequences are convergent.
So if this is Cauchy, then
it's convergent and vice versa.
So based on what we've
proven already for sequences,
it follows that--
and this just
follows immediately
from what we've proven
already, so I'm not even
going to write a proof--
a series is Cauchy if and only
if the series is convergent--
again, because both
are defined in terms
of the sequence of partial
sums associated to the series.
And we've already proven the
equivalence between Cauchy
and convergence for sequences.
Now, let me write what
it means to be Cauchy
in a slightly different way.
And it's the following.
So before, we had that
a sequence is Cauchy,
intuitively, if the
elements of the sequence
are getting close to each other.
Now, for a series to be
Cauchy, the intuitive way
to think about it is
that the tail of the sum
is getting small, is
getting arbitrarily
small, the tail of the
sum being if I add up
finitely many numbers
far enough out.
So a series is
Cauchy if and only
if all epsilon positive there
exist to M, a natural number,
such that for all integers
l bigger than m, which
is bigger than or equal to
capital M, the sum from n
equals n plus 1
to l of x sub n--
so this is a sum involving
terms that are pretty far out
there, at least all
indexed by something bigger
than or equal to capital M--
is less than epsilon.
So a series is Cauchy
if you're adding up
smaller and smaller pieces, not
individual pieces but actual
adding those up.
So I'll leave it to you to do--
they're both pretty
easy-- but this direction,
I'll leave it to
you as an exercise.
And it'll follow
immediately from what
I'm going to write for,
essentially, this direction.
So let's suppose-- and
let's make things concrete,
starting somewhere-- let's
suppose this sum is Cauchy.
And we want to prove now
that it has this property.
So let epsilon be positive.
We now want to produce
some capital number
M so that this holds.
So since the sequence of
partial sums s sub m is Cauchy--
that's what it means for
the series to be Cauchy--
there exists a natural
number, capital M,
such that for all M
bigger than or equal to M0
and l bigger than or equal
to M0, s sub m minus s
sub l is less than epsilon.
So we're actually going to
take capital M to be this M0.
Choose M to be M0.
Then, if l is
bigger than m, which
is bigger than or equal to
M, which is equal to M0,
if I look at this sum from n
equals m plus 1 to l x sub n,
I can write--
so this is absolute value.
So in fact, let me remove
the absolute value so
that this becomes pretty clear.
I can write this sum
as the l-th partial sum
minus the n-th partial sum.
Because the l-th partial sum
sums from n equals 1 up to l.
The m-th partial sums
from n equals 1 up to m.
So the sum containing only the
terms between n plus 1 and l
is the difference of these guys.
So now I'll put it
on absolute values.
And this thing,
because l and m are
bigger than or equal to capital
M, which is equal to M0,
and because I have
this inequality,
this is less than epsilon.
And the converse
direction, again, it
follows immediately,
essentially,
from this equality here.
So to check whether
a series converges,
I don't have to somehow come up
with a limit for this series,
a sum for this series.
I can just prove
that the tail can
be made arbitrarily
small, as long
as I go far enough
out in the series.
And from this, we get a pretty
simple elementary property,
so a theorem.
If a series converges, then
this implies that the limit as n
goes to infinity of x sub
n of the sequence you used
to obtain the series equals 0.
So this should fall in line
with a series being convergent
if and only if it satisfies this
property here, which is somehow
saying the tail of the sum is
getting smaller and smaller,
which means you can't be adding
up big things as you go on
out in the series.
So proof.
So we'll show this by a
simple epsilon M definition.
So suppose xn converges.
Then xn the series is Cauchy.
And now I'm going to verify this
using the epsilon M definition.
Let epsilon be positive.
Since xn is Cauchy,
this implies that there
exists a natural number M0
such that for all l bigger
than or equal to m
bigger than or equal M0,
I have that condition there,
sum from n equals m plus 1
to l x sub n is
less than epsilon.
Choose M to be M0 plus 1.
So why M0 plus 1
but not exactly M0?
Just because, basically,
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take l
to be equal to m plus 1.
And the index gets shifted by 1.
Then if m is bigger
than or equal to M,
I get that the absolute
value of x sub m--
maybe instead of
saying limit as n
goes to infinity, I'll write
limit as m goes to infinity,
it's just a change in
the dummy variable-- this
is equal to the sum from
n equals m to m x sub n.
And so I've shifted this.
So now little m is bigger than
or equal to capital M0 plus 1.
So you could write this as,
if you like, m minus 1 plus 1.
So little m minus 1 is
bigger than or equal to M0.
So by this inequality,
this is less than epsilon.
So we see that if a series
converges the terms,
the individual terms, x
sub n must converge to 0.
So there's another reason why
this series minus 1 to the n
does not converge.
Because those terms
do not converge.
And this also tells us that
for this geometric series, when
r is greater than or equal
to 1 in absolute value,
the series does not converge.
It does not converge.
And the proof is--
and we proved this, in fact,
I think, a few lectures ago,
as well, that if the absolute
value of r is bigger than 1,
then the limit as n goes
to infinity of r to the n,
this limit does not exist.
We showed it's, in
fact, unbounded.
r to the n is an
unbounded sequence.
So it does not convert.
So I'm using that
theorem over there
in a little bit roundabout way.
Let me restate this
theorem over here.
This theorem says if
the series converges,
then this limit equals 0.
Now, this statement is logically
equivalent to the negation
of the converse, or there's
an actual word for that,
but I can't remember--
namely that the negation of this
implies the negation of this.
So a logically equivalent way
to rewrite that statement over
there is that if this
limit does not equal to 0--
so if it doesn't exist at
all, that's also fine--
this implies that
does not converge.
So this restatement of
the theorem over there
is really what I used here.
All right.
And I think I'll stop there.
Next time, we'll see
that this theorem here
is a one-way street.
And I think you covered
this example in, probably,
calculus, namely that
one-way street in the sense
that if x then converges,
then this limit is 0.
But the converse does not hold.
Namely, it is not true
that if this limit
is 0, then this converges.
And we'll see the famed
harmonic series next time.